[Music]  [Music]  michael is a big guy he works out a lot  you know he's there's a lot of area to  cover  [Music]  [Music]  some of the biggest challenges was a  warrior fall sequence where he's not  only in the water  he's fighting there's a lot of body  contact there's a lot of rubbing you  know and water is natural enemy of  makeup anyway  [Music]  we borrowed our inspiration from the  Mersey tribe in Africa  [Music]  [Music]  being a part of Black Panther it's  tremendously satisfying to see the  reception that this movie has gotten all  of our performers embracing these looks  you know embracing the message behind  this movie made for a pretty magical  experience filming it but more so watch  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  you